I was flabbergasted watching this
thinking why hadn't this happened before
there I think there are a lot of
different answers I think Nina is
someone we we need right now I think it
there's you know a rebirth of a movement
and I think Nina's music is something
that coincides with that rebirth and I
so I think there there's a need for her
I think that there the estate of Nina
Simone was ready for a whole bunch of
reasons to allow a filmmaker to have
creative freedom
to tell me a story I think that was a
hard place for them to get to because
Nina's story had been yeah it's so often
misunderstood and misrepresented and I
think that's you know I think those are
the the reasons that there was a
readiness for it to happen now and there
and there was a trust that I had from
them did you go into this making a film
about one woman and come out the other
end finding that this was a different
woman I think Nina to me is she's many
different women and I think to her fans
she's also she means different things to
different people I think for some people
she's a Civil Rights icon for other
people she's a virtuoso musician for
other people she's a boundary busting
feminist you know rock star her to to
look up to so I think you know she's
many different things
she's someone with of course an
endlessly complex psychology you know
when I started making the film I didn't
realize the depth of all those different
elements but I came to appreciate them
as I listened to her and I read her her
Diaries and letters and you know that
IIIi knew those aspects I didn't
appreciate their the depths and the the
sort of craggy facets of that each of
them had I would imagine the
documentarian has two nightmares which
are different sides of the same coin one
being too little material and one being
too much which side were you on
well you know the music is like this
incredible you know gift and and wealth
and you know
gret you know that to kind of choose
amongst Nina's songs is you know a most
delicious dilemma you know at the end of
the day we chose songs by you know their
their narrative value that we use songs
to advance the narrative not just you
know because of their purely aesthetic
qualities or how much I might just love
a song and you know that we started off
from it with an archival point of view
on this film we wanted to find as much
Nina as we could and one of the great
gifts was the audio we found all the
interviews which started as early as 59
and go through the late 90s of Nina
telling her story to various
interviewers or Co biographers when she
was working on her her memoir and so we
had a wealth of Nina talking about her
own life stuff that you know had never
been collected or listened to except by
those interviewers and that was
wonderful you know that was an
extraordinary gift to really listen to
her processing her own the questions
about her own life that interviewers
were asking her there were moments that
you recreated when she's a little girl
playing piano in the church and walking
along those dangerous railroad tracks
how did you come to decide that was the
way to tell that part of the story well
we found wonderful archival material by
a documentarian working in the South and
the 30s and 40s and 50s named H Lee
Waters who shot everyday life in small
southern towns and so I felt like we
could paint a picture of Nina's
environment as a child with that footage
except this little girl playing the
piano so we chose to kind of you know I
studied a chilly waters material and
then we chose to shoot a little girl
playing the piano to kind of put Nina in
that environment that we found there and
working with the family working with the
estate was there veto-power was what
what what power was put into your hands
is the filmmaker
well I had ultimately the final cut of
the film and Lisa the Nina's daughter
was extraordinary I mean I met her when
I first pitched myself as a director for
the project
I didn't talk to her until you know I
well and we had a great meeting and we
talked and she told me some of her
stories and then I met her again nine
months later when I spent a day
interviewing her and then I showed her
the film you know another six or seven
eight months later before the film went
to Sundance and she hadn't she gave no
comment she had no notes and she said
you know mommy's story's been told the
truth is out there and I can I can move
on and that was the that was her
interaction with the film I mean and
that was that was all of it in terms of
any kind of yeah there were there was
never of a veto of anything and for her
daughter did her daughter ask anything
of you the question of I want this film
to tell this about my mother I mean I
think the domestic violence that went on
in her home that was important for her
to express that and have that be
corroborated by others who I spoke to I
think that was also important to her I
think it's in there I think what she
talked about and you know what I put in
the film is it was what was it that was
what was important to her to express
about her mom what what influence do you
think she's had nowadays on music it's
huge I mean the artists today who kind
of give props to Nina Simone or feel
like they're standing on her shoulders
are some of the greatest artists and you
can't and there's so many of them who
kind of have you know express support
and inspiration from her you know from
you know people like Alicia Keys to
people like Lauryn Hill to John Legend
to comment I mean there's a real Bob
Dylan you know I mean there's just a
love and a regard for her amongst
musicians and performers that's pretty
stunning as a documentarian you can
finish the film but do you ever leave
the subject does it stay with you no and
the most wonderful thing about Nina is
you know you can just I can listen to
her all the time and have this you know
kind of very three-dimensional rich
experience of a human being so I'm like
you know Bobby Fischer I can't just look
at a chess match and kind of you know
with you know we can all be SPN have a
chess channel that you
I really don't but but but you know it's
wonderful to have Nina around you know
all the time and you know I listen to
her all the time and my kids in all
hours on it
do you think that she will now be more
regarded in this country in death in
part because of your bringing back her
music and in a time in a context where
her politics may be more meaningful or
acceptable I don't know I mean I I think
that there seems to be a moment of
celebration I mean I went into Starbucks
the other day and they were playing
Yoona Simone
I mean maybe they've always been doing
that but there does seem to be a desire
for her music right now and I'm sure
that the film is well is one part of
that and there are other artists you
know performing arts and musicians or
doing tributes to her and yeah I think
that that that maybe she'll yeah she'll
she'll be around us more yeah well thank
you for bringing us this story of a
remarkable American whose story I think
was largely unknown thank you so much
thank you
thank you